-♪ "Mad Lib Theater," uh-huh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Light laughter ]
-Good evening...
my little cookie.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
-Special Director Pollywog...
[ Laughter ]
...it's good to see you again.
-I'm here
with your next mission.
A criminal organization
of the world's
most amazing
sanitation engineers
hacked into
the government's Walkman,
stealing their top-secret report
on vintage sneakers.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come here, darling.
[ Laughter ]
-I understand your reaction.
The group also kidnapped
your Aunt Ingrid
and is holding her for a ransom
of 1,000,256 sofas.
[ Laughter ]
-Where the doodie-head are
we gonna get 1,000,256 sofas?
-I don't know,
but we have to move fast.
-I have a plan.
I'll meet up with the group,
disguising as myself --
disguising myself
as Huckleberry Finn.
Jesus...
[ Laughter ]
-So far --
So far, I'm on board.
-If they attack,
I'll fight back with a knife.
[ Laughter ]
-Great.
This disk contains sensitive
information that might help.
-What's on this disk?
-Seven photos
of Ingrid Bergman running.
[ Laughter ]
-Come here, darling.
I've already contacted my team
of highly humongous lemmings...
[ Laughter ]
...to help.
-You're the best agent we have.
How do you prepare
for such tense missions?
-By waking up every morning,
going up on the roof,
and kissing
and by repeating
my own personal mantra --
"Poopy-di-scoop,
poopy-di-scoop."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
And scene!
[ Applause ]
[ Soft, dramatic music plays ]
[ Light laughter ]
-I'm Christian Grey.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm Anastasia Barf-barf.
[ Chuckles ]
-Let's make this quick.
I only have...two weeks.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Clears throat ]
Um, this interview is for
the special
Independence Day issue
of the student newspaper.
-Mm-hmm.
-You are very psychedelic
to have amassed such an empire.
To what do you owe your success?
-By following the same routine
every morning --
waking up, brushing my teeth.
and then...
[ Laughter ]
...pinching at the gym.
[ Applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Hmm.
-Ooh.
-Your company
is involved primarily
in agricultural projects,
feeding the world's penguins.
[ Laughter ]
What's...
[ Laughs ]
With that kind of passion,
I wonder if your knee
might be...
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-What's that?
Did you remember
an old joke or something?
[ Laughter ]
-I wonder if your knee
might be bigger than you let on.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
-[ Chuckles ]
Some -- Some people say
I don't have a knee at all.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you.
-I did some research on you,
and I see that you're unmarried
[Clears throat] and that you
were adopted at age 49.
[ Laughter ]
-A late adoption. That's why.
♪♪
You intrigue me, Ms. Barf-barf.
[ Laughter ]
And so when someone...
When someone intrigues...
[ Laughter ]
...I tickle excessively.
[ Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
-My sock is sweating.
[ Laughter ]
-Whew.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-What are your plans
after you graduate?
-I was planning on moving
to Detroit with Beyoncé.
[ Laughter ]
-The best part about
having success is getting
to give students like you
my favorite piece of advice.
Baby, come back.
[ Laughter ]
-When I'm around you,
I feel like a Zamboni driver
at a funeral.
[ Laughter ]
You know?
[ Chuckles ]
-I've heard that before.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Well, I hope you got
everything you need.
-I did. I did.
And whenever I have
a great interview,
I do my favorite dance,
called the hairless sausage.
[ Laughter ]
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
-Dang!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And scene!
[ Soft, dramatic music plays ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
This really is...
[ Both laugh ]
Really is a beautiful day
to go, uh, apple picking.
This is the most fun
I've had in 6,000 years.
[ Laughter ]
-Listen, Donald,
I-I've been thinking,
and we need to talk.
-What is it, Fuzzy?
[ Laughter ]
-Hmm.
What I'm about to say
might be stinky to hear,
but here it goes.
I think we should break up.
-I hate candy!
[ Laughter ]
-I'm so sorry.
We've -- We've shared so much
over the past 17 weeks,
but...last call.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-That's cold.
-[ Chuckles ]
-How long have you been
feeling this way?
-[ Laughing ] Since
the Revolutionary War.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I can't believe this.
Is this because
of my slimy knees?
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, it's not.
We're just --
We're just really
different people.
Um, I was brought up
by two scuba divers.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And you were raised by llamas?
I enjoy --
-[ Spitting ]
-I enjoy going out,
and come home every night
to find you ghosting
on the couch,
watching YouTube videos
of Kim Kardashian
eating bananas.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Chuckles ]
I understand.
Well, I have something
to tell you, too,
that's not easy to admit.
I've been cheating on you
with Rachel from "Friends."
[ Laughter ]
-You couldn't carry
a blank strap!
[ Laughter ]
-You -- You suck at "Fortnite"!
-Well, you cook --
you look like a Cheeto!
[ Laughter ]
I'm taking the chairs
and moving out.
-Hey, hey, please --
please don't flush.
[ Laughter ]
It's a term that my
llama parents used to say.
[ Laughter ]
I hate seeing you do that.
So have a seat here.
I'm sorry
things didn't work out.
-I am, too.
I -- I'll...
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
I'll...
I'll -- I'll always have a
special place for you
in my butt.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause
continue ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
-It's during...
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
It's during times like this,
I like for us to recite
our favorite love quotes.
[ Chuckles ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-"You got to fart
like Mickey Mouse is watching."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"And you got to love
like there's nobody sniffing."
And scene.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dings ]
-Good afternoon,
ladies and gentlemen.
Welcome aboard
Aah! Airlines Flight 8072,
with nonstop service to Narnia.
I'm -- I'm Ron Googly.
[ Laughter ]
-And I'm Miss [Imitates static].
-And I am Mark,
but you can call me
Chuck Joerger.
[ Laughter ]
Now, we do apologize
for the 14 nanoseconds' delay,
because we are stalled
because Gila monsters
are farting on the runway.
[ Laughter ]
-Before we depart
on this flight,
we ask you to pay attention
to this quickly.
safety announcement.
-Ensure all your mobile devices,
including smartphones, tablets,
and MRIs...
[ Laughter ]
...are turned off and stowed.
If we see you using one,
we'll kindly come up and say,
"It's mariachi night."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-You're welcome.
There are 12 1/2 exits
on this plane.
-The half one is the hidden one.
[ Laughter ]
You got to find that one.
That's the good one.
-Please take a moment
to look around
and find the nearest Chili's.
[ Laughter ]
In the event of a SantaCon,
a dirty underwear will drop down
from your seat above.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You might want to pull it down
and kind of deal with it.
-If you have a child,
put it over the child.
You know, the child first,
then you, yeah.
-Ladies and gentlemen, our
in-flight entertainment today
is a YouTube clip of Awkwafina's
video from "My Vag."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And also a bonus documentary
about Awkwafina
learning how to run.
-Oh, I've seen that.
That's good.
-So good.
-If you have any questions,
like, "How long will it take
to get to the airport?"
don't hesitate to ask
by raising your belly button
and waving it.
-Now, this holiday season,
we at Aah! Airline
hope you get to be
in "Star Wars."
-We also wish
you get to be in "Star Wars."
Did you say that?
-I just said that.
-I think we both
said the same thing.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for flying
with Aah! Airlines.
And on behalf of
Captain Little Steve
and all of us...
-Wanna make whoopee?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And scene!
[ Soft music plays ]
-[ Sighing ] Oh.
Sure having a great night.
This is a great, great time
on this date tonight, Popeye.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm having fun as well, Pinto.
-[ Chuckling ] Oh.
-Did you enjoy your lamb shank?
-Yes, I did.
-Great. So, uh, tell me
a little bit about yourself.
-Oh, okay. So...
Um, I grew up
in a small town in Greece,
um, for kayaking.
-Yeah.
-And, um, but I hated it.
Most people do.
Which is why you don't hear
about that a lot.
And then I just decided
to pack up and buy a Vespa
and just move to Bob's Big Boy.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
That's where my grandma,
Auntie Pete Seeger, lives.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Gasps ]
-Grandma Auntie lives
at Bob's Big Boy, yeah.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
-I should...
[ Laughter ]
I should've washed my hair.
-Yeah. Right.
[ Laughter ]
-Well -- Well, how about you,
Popeye?
What do you do for a living?
-I'm a very successful
astronaut.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-But my real passion is digging.
Give me a spoon, and
put me out in the backyard.
-My God.
Why, Popeye,
that's my
favorite activity, too.
-Well, what do you like to do
for fun?
-I just said I like digging.
-Yeah, I was listening, yeah.
-Well, I, um...
-What else?
-I enjoy collecting bikinis.
-Oh, yeah?
-I think you know
what that means.
And taking long walks to France.
-Is that right?
It's a lot of steps
on your Fitbit.
Uh...
[ Laughter ]
Listen, Pinto, there's something
I have to tell you.
-Can we eat our bread, already?
-Oh, yeah.
We're done with dinner.
-Oh, we're done?
-We're finished with dinner.
Yes, it's the end.
-Yes, I said that earlier.
-Check, please.
I'm getting the check,
but it's going well.
I have something to tell you.
-Okay. God, I'm nervous.
What is it?
-Okay. [ Clears throat ]
[ Sighs ]
Here goes nothing.
[ Chuckles ]
-Yeah?
-I live with 52
untrustworthy rhinos.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, [Bleep].
Aw, dagnabbit.
-I -- I understand
your reaction.
A lot of people
respond that way.
-No, no, I'm just I'm just glad
you're being honest.
You know, I really like you,
Popeye.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not just 'cause
you have nice ears.
[ Laughter ]
-This feels right.
-Yeah.
Hey, listen, Valentine's Day
is almost here.
Do you mind if I -- if I recite
my favorite Valentine's poem?
-Oh, my goodness.
I'd love to hear you, yeah.
-Thank you. Okay.
-Are you gonna stand up?
-I'm gonna stand up
and face you.
I hope the other diners
don't mind.
-I'm happy there's no one else
at the restaurant.
Picked the greatest --
[ Laughter ]
I don't know how we got
a reservation here, yeah.
-Um...
-Oh, yeah, so, the...
-Okay.
[ Soft music plays ]
"Roses are flashy,
violets are spies,
deodorant is sweet,
and so are eyes."
[ Laughter ]
-That is beautiful!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And scene. Here we go.